Yeah,
well I think first of all,
if we didn't have electronic
applications that you wouldn't see quite
that same kind of growth.
I think a second of all is that,
uh,
that I,
I see that as a good sign because those,
those institutions are a recognized as
being.
Institutions have great excellence
worldwide excellence.
So if more and more students think of
themselves as world class scholars,
uh,
it's great that there's that many kids
that want to go out to the very best
schools.
Uh,
when I,
when I talked to parents and students,
what I emphasize is there's so many
great schools in America and is a
minister told me once when I was quite
young and he was talking about the
people that came to him for advice.
He said,
I told him there is not a college or
university you go to that you can learn
all they have to teach you.
So I believe that we have a great number
of great institutions in this country
and your future doesn't depend upon
going to the very best that people can
get a great education.
And,
uh,
if you look at people that are
successful in this country,
not all of them have gone.
Certainly many of them haven't gone to
what we would consider the most elite
schools in the school.